- I'm very excited.
I know, I'm very excited.
- I'm excited.
- I'm so excited.
You look so handsome in
your suit, I love it.
I understand that we both have ranches,
so where's yours?
- Well, I won't tell you.
- [Kelly] Okay, yeah.
- It's in the vicinity.
- [Kelly] It's in the vicinity, oh.
- Somewhere in Ventura County.
- Oh, in California?
- Yes, yeah.
- Mine's in Montana.
Yeah, I didn't be like, what's, what's ...
What are the ...
Wouldn't that be funny
- Oh, Montana?
if I was like what's your exact location?
- Yes, mine is in Montana.
So, yours is in California.
- Yeah, I've been there
since the end of Magnum.
- [Kelly] Yeah?
- And I love it.
Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah.
Do you personally work the ranch?
- Yeah, well, that's what I do for fun.
I work.
- That's awesome, yeah.
- I mean, I ...
- Do, y'all do any -
- We've got a lot of Oak trees
and I have planted a lot of native Oaks.
We're pretty green at my place.
We're on well water, we
don't have any city water.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And I have this whole family of trees
'cause I've been there, oh, 25 years.
I don't know.
- That's amazing,
you've been able to see it grow.
- I have have little
babies that I just planted
and teenagers, and now I
got some grownup trees.
- I love that, though -
- And I watch 'em grow.
- It takes forever to watch them grow,
so, it's awesome like
when you planted them now,
they're still -
- I can see it.
- [Kelly] I know, that's awesome.
- I can see the little bits of growth.
- I think that's really cool.
So, wait, you also have grandchildren.
You enjoy grandchildren, right?
- I do have grandchildren
and I love 'em dearly.
- Yeah.
Are they crazy?
Are they all over the place?
- No, they're all centrally
located near the ranch
so I get to see 'em.
- [Kelly] Oh, that's cool.
- Not as often as I'd like
with the Covid stuff and all.
We were under, as you were I'm sure -
- Quarantine, yeah.
- And everybody was,
really strict protocols.
- Yeah.
- I couldn't get sick 'cause
if I don't go to work about 200
people don't go to work, so.
- That, I'm telling you what,
that was so stressful on me.
- Yeah.
- Like, I never got it, like, ahhh
(Kelly knocking on wood)
but I was like, that was so stressful
'cause it like so many people
are gonna be out of work
if I get sick and you can't help it.
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] Like, you're doing all you can.
- [Kelly] That was a lot of pressure.
- But they don't call me Grandpa.
- They don't call you Grandpa?
- No, they call me Hoppy.
- [Kelly] Oh, why Hoppy?
Do you bounce a lot?
(Kelly laughing)
- When I was born,
my dad was in the army
air force in World War II
and he didn't see me
until I was two years old.
So, I lived with my
grandparents and my mom.
And that was Mimi and Hoppy.
- Yeah.
- So,
when we had kids,
all of my dad and mom's kids,
we started calling my dad Hoppy.
- Oh, so it's a passed down -
- I asked my son, Kevin,
the first time they called me Grandpa,
I said, could they call me Hoppy?
- [Kelly] Yeah, I love that.
It's like special to your family.
- Yeah, so I'm Hoppy.
(audience applauding)
- That was a look at his
CBS show, Blue Bloods.
So, the characters on your show,
they have family dinners all the time.
So, do y'all do cast dinners?
Cause y'all are around each other a lot.
- We do real dinners
for about eight hours.
(Kelly laughing)
Food gets a little cold.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And you know, in film work
you kind of repeat what you do
as the camera moves around,
so whatever you choose
to eat at the beginning,
you're just gonna have to re-eat it,
and re-eat it, and re-eat it.
- [Kelly] Continuity.
- But that's fine.
Listen, I love our cast.
- Yeah.
- We have a family of actors,
as well as a family of characters.
We all catch up, Donnie
and Bridget and Will
and Len and everybody.
So, about every eight days
we see each other
and we have a good time.
- I know, I think it's funny -
- And it shows, I think.
- And I think it does too,
the chemistry, especially.
But it's funny, sometimes I always laugh
that I see my work family
more than I see my
actual family sometimes.
Cause you know, you're working a lot.
- Yeah.
- Especially with a commute like that.
So, "Blue Bloods", it just did it's,
is it 250th episode?
That's incredible.
- Yeah, I know.
- That's incredible.
(audience applauding)
How does that feel?
- Well, I don't know where the time went.
- [Kelly] I know it, flies, yeah.
- But, yeah, we did a 163 hours of Magnum,
and I thought, well okay, you
can't get that lucky twice.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- It was a really lovely
little celebration.
- It's a blessing -
- Boy, I'll say.
- to have a show
that everybody loves like that.
- Yeah, I got a mortgage.
(Kelly laughing)
- And it's just a blessing,
you love what you do, right?
And it's awesome when people -
- I love what I do.
And I wanna keep doing
it, and so far so good.
- [Kelly] I know, people are digging it.
You're a hit.
- Yeah, twelve years.
- That's crazy.
And not only just 12 years, but
your entire career is crazy.
It's a remarkable career.
- It is crazy.
The hardest thing is to guest on a show.
- [Kelly] Yeah?
- It's really hard.
- 'Cause they just mess it up?
(Kelly laughing)
I'm just kidding.
- I try to relax the new actors
'cause that's really
hard to come on a show
where everybody's up to speed.
It's like when I did "Friends",
they were up to speed.
They read the script.
- You were amazing in "Friends"!
(audience applauding)
Did you like doing the sitcom thing?
- I wasn't amazing at what
they call the table read.
- Who cares?
Bad rehearsal, good show.
Like, no, that was so good.
That's like literally
the thing I feel like
people comment about all the time,
was when Monica's on
your voicemail breezy.
- [Tom] Yeah.
- And like you were just so great.
Did you like doing the sitcom?
- I was scared to death.
I had done "Taxi" a long time before,
but I hadn't done a sitcom
and so I was really nervous.
And Courtney helped a lot.
Courtney's a big help.
But that group is,
it's just an incredible group of friends.
- [Kelly] Yeah, yeah,
it was good chemistry.
- They obviously became friends in life
as well as on the show, and it shows.
And it was a wonderful place to work.
And we ended up doing about nine of them.
- I know, I watched all of them.
- I was only supposed to do three.
- Well, that's how good you are.
I was like, people love you.
I don't know if you know this.
(audience applauding)
So, America loves a good mustache
and I gotta be honest with you,
I mean, you are Steve
Harvey's, Ron Bergundy's -
- America loves a good mustache.
- They love a good mustache.
I'm telling you, look
at all these mustaches.
We love a good mustache.
So, be honest.
'Cause you're affiliated
with a mustache for life,
regardless if you want to or not,
how do you feel about that?
Do you ever just wanna shave any it off?
- I was born that way.
(audience laughing)
- It looks like a solid mustache, though.
When did that grow in, like 15?
- I haven't had time.
Somewhere along the line,
when puberty struck.
- I was gonna say it had to be,
'cause that's a thick mustache, yeah.
- Before Magnum, I worked
most of the time without it.
- [Kelly] I know, but
you wear it so well, sir.
- Maybe that's why I
did six unsold pilots.
- Yeah, I'm just saying,
but maybe that's why you needed it.
(Kelly laughing)
It's just a really great mustache.
So, your look on Magnum PI -
- My mustache has its own agent.
- It's agent?
(Kelly laughing)
It should.
But that's such a classic look, Magnum PI.
I just wanna see that
photo, show everybody again,
remind you of how good this looks.
- [Tom] Whoa.
- Yeah!
(audience cheering)
There is nothing that says I am truly hot
like a Hawaiian shirt.
Okay, I'm sure that you know
that people love that
Magnum PI look so much,
but they still dress like you.
And actually one of
those people works here,
and her name is Tegan.
So, here's this photo.
(Kelly laughing)
Look at her trying to like cop your ...
There's Tegan over there.
- Hi Tom.
- See, we love the look.
- I love the mustache.
- Thank you.
- And when puberty hits
it'll really come in.
(Tegan laughing)
- I'm telling you, that's
not true for everyone.
I have dated guys that
can't grow mustaches.
- Some people can't.
- [Kelly] It's a gift.
- Ashton Kutcher told me he
couldn't grow a good mustache.
- [Kelly] I know, he has the
boyish look thing, right?
- Yeah.
- You got that straight up I'm a man.
(audience laughing)
- I'm disappointed that
you didn't wear the shorts.
- It was cold and Halloween.
- I get a lot of short questions,
'cause they're short.
- You know what though?
They were short then
back in the day, though.
But if you got nice legs.
- That's what shorts are.
Shorts are shorts.
- They are, but ...
- And those pajama bottoms
that they wore for about
the last decade are silly.
- Are they?
- And you can trip on 'em.
- And you know what?
They're coming back up.
- They are on some people,
but on others that don't have
maybe the legs for shorts.
- The shorts are coming back
to where they should be.
(Kelly laughing)
- I love that you're
like into short-shorts.
This is the most fabulous thing
that will happen to me today,
you talking about how we
need to wear short-shorts.
- Well, I cheated.
You know, I read the script,
and I knew if I had a
fight scene coming up
I wouldn't wear the shorts.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- 'Cause I wanted to put pads
underneath my jeans and stuff.
- [Kelly] Keep it safe.
- I cheated that way,
but it's hot over there.
- I'm just saying, not everybody
can sport shorts like that.
Well done, sir.
- I know that.
(Kelly laughing)
Well, I played basketball
right up until college
when I actually sat on the bench
at USC,
instead of playing all the time.
- [Kelly] You're not
bitter about it, though.
- That happens to athletes.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- But it didn't affect my legs.
- They still look great.
(Kelly laughing)
The legs and the mustache, you got it all.
- I should have worn shorts today.
- You should have worn shorts.
Next time, if you don't wear shorts,
I'm promising you this,
I won't be in shorts.
It's a big ol' booty.
- I don't think I will either.
It's not pretty anymore.
- I've always had a big butt,
so like even when I was a
kid, when I wear shorts,
like the short ones,
you can see your butt.
So that's why I don't like short-shorts.
- Yeah.
- Cause some of us
have a lot of junk in the trunk, okay?
Look at Lester back there.
(Kelly laughing)
Lester's like, there's nothing
wrong with that, ma'am.
Thank you so much.
There's no way to end that.
There's no segue from that.
Thank you so much for being here.
I'm such a big fan.
We love this show.
- My pleasure.
- Everybody, you can see
"Blue Bloods" Fridays on CBS.